[Applause]
[Music]
the end of the month is a great time to
revisit games you might have missed out
on when they first launched hold on hold
on don't go I've got some new stuff to
talk about - I've got guns and sports
let's talk about some of the big games
dropping this week far cry 5 is looking
to close out the month with a bang the
series is known for some pretty exotic
settings but this time you're being
dropped right into the American Midwest
where a cult has overtaken the whole
county cue the usual gun filled missions
full of commandeered vehicles and all
sorts of crazy firefights only this time
you're fighting to let people back into
their home's not just take down enemy
encampments you can load up on ps4 Xbox
one and PC on Tuesday March 27th and if
you want to look at the crazy arcade
mode we've got a tour of some trippy
custom maps you can check out right now
enough about the alternative midwest
let's talk about America's favorite
pastime MLB the show a teen is throwing
a changeup this year giving you more
options for creating a character right
down to their batting stance also coming
our better physics and improvements to
the classic Road to the show career mode
meanwhile Diamond Dynasty gives you more
choices and the missions you take on
while franchise mode will now be broken
up into phases like regular season and
draft day you can take a swing on ps4 on
Tuesday the 27th you can also revisit
the DC Universe this week with injustice
to legendary edition if you didn't play
the original fighter this version
includes the base game and all
previously released DLC that means you
can play as Darkseid Red Hood and even
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles right
from the start
tons of premiere skins are also packed
in and you can dig into all of that good
stuff on ps4 Xbox one and PC on the 27th
I'm just hoping injustice will cross
over with the Wonder Twins someday
[Music]
come on Jana
it's up to us to stop bolt aliens out
last two also creeped on his shelves
last year but now you'll be able to take
on all those jump scares on the go with
the switch version Blake and Lin Lang
Ehrman are investigating a murder of a
young woman and their case will take
them from the cultish town of temple
gate to the vast Arizona desert there's
no word on whether this port will make
use of the joy Khan's HD Rumble feature
but I'm guessing you'll be scared
regardless when outlast 2 comes to
switch on the 27th and finally what's an
episode of new releases without a steam
game this week's pick is long gone days
a modern day military RPG where your
mission isn't quite what it seems and
not just because of the cool-looking
first-person turn-based combat after
deserting the army your personal mission
to stop all war takes priority it's
definitely a huge undertaking but you
can give it your best shot on PC on
Wednesday the 28th and those are some of
the hottest games we'll be playing this
week as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with a
look at April's big games next Sunday